[Music]
thanks for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show talking to bow in
Orlando he's a custom home builder after
the last downturn he decided to hoard
cash and he did a good job of it he's
got four hundred fifteen thousand cent
in cash
is that a fair summary of what you told
me so far sir yes sir it is I don't need
a little kick in the pants to move this
one way or the other because it's not
doing anybody any good where it's at
yeah it's costing about 40,000 a year
not having it in something that's pretty
substantial so yeah probably needs to be
in something but the trick is you know
what you want to do with it what's your
long-term plan for that money well you
know I grew up in a family I've been
very blessed to have essentially the
same principles you've teach you know
you're you're remarkable you do such a
good service for those out there and I
really been unable to keep my whole
lifestyle out of debt I've got two young
children a wonderful wife who is
ingrained in our company as well and
knowing you know how cash got me through
the difficult times I'm just I'm almost
paralyzed to pay off the rest of my debt
in my personal house because now I know
I'm depleting those funds and then of
course taking the rest of those funds
and putting them into some kind of
investment I do have other investments
but again going through such a horrible
time it almost made me paralyzed to do
anything you're risk-averse because I
would I don't blame you so how much do
you owe on your home ninety-three
thousand okay that's kind of a
no-brainer I mean I still leave you 300
grand you write that young today yeah
I'll be done with that and that's your
last debt that's it nothing else you
know you are payments I'm kind of stuck
in baby step 7 no not anymore by the end
of day you're debt-free just write that
check ninety three thousand out of 415 I
mean you're still sitting there were
three hundred and some thousand dollars
I
you know and if you don't like me in
debt for you can go get you a mortgage
later okay you're gonna love it you're
gonna you're gonna go I wish I'd done
that years ago okay
because it's something which is gonna
flip inside of you that you're gonna go
wow that feels good okay now then what
to do with that other 300,000 so what is
your household income what do you guys
make a year net profit taxable income
well that's kind of the profit it's very
cyclical it just goes very drastic what
isn't what here will be approximately
two hundred thousand this year the year
afterwards might be a hundred thousand
calm and alright so let's say that let's
say that just I want a fund of cash that
I'm not gonna make any money on it's
just there to make me feel good about
yeah cyclical right how much does that
fund need to be a hundred grand
that's what I was thinking exactly that
number okay that's pretty rich for an
emergency fund but you're in a very
volatile business agreed and you've been
stung a couple times and so you're just
what you're saying is is that the money
I would have made on that hundred
thousand I'm willing to give up just to
have it sitting there to make me feel
good
correct I'm gonna give up approximately
ten thousand dollars a year because it's
just gonna sit there that's okay by the
way that's okay I don't I don't just
like that plan at all mmm-hmm okay so
let's set a hundred let's pay off the
house let's set a hundred aside for that
so now we still got two hundred left
what are we gonna do with that well
that's where you know here we are the
markets done so great you know we're
seeing a lot of swings and you know I
I've kind of gotten to this mental state
of I don't want to give any of it back
so when I go into something that's more
of a growth stock mutual fund or more of
a conservative mindset and you know
still making money but still kind of
there or am I just being too
conservative you know what I think you
would do I think you go got some dirt
I'd love to do that
my my my entrepreneurial spirit is just
bubbling inside right now that's that's
kind of what I want to do but I just
don't want to put my family
you're not risk because they're nice
they're not you're under 100% debt free
of $100,000 in the bank you're fine you
make 200 a year or a hundred a year
you're all right
oh why is it so difficult to get over
this hurdle it's not it's July it's well
because you've been burned I mean and
that just that's a human nature you're
some you would be an unwise rash
immature person if you weren't having
these feelings with with the volatility
you've been through in the business yeah
it's tough you know if you crash your
car into the wall the next time you get
in the car and drive it it's it so you
know you worried about hitting the wall
you know so it's just normal but here's
the thing if you go possum paid-for dirt
no no mortgages just go buy a piece of
dirt somewhere that maybe someday you
put some houses on or maybe you just
want to own some dirt to hold the world
together or maybe you buy a little
rental house for 200 grand or something
in the Orlando market and it makes you a
little money that's okay but listen yeah
you're gonna do better because of your
knowledge of real estate and building
you're going to do better in real estate
than you are in emotionally and
financially both you're gonna do better
there than you are playing in mutual
funds well that's what my my financial
adviser kind of wants to get that two
hundred thousand and I I try to be as
respectful as possible in that I I
believe in his profession I trust in
what he's doing but I feel like through
my experience and what I have done over
the course of my 44 years I'm I can make
it grow quicker but you come with a lot
more risk no it doesn't come with a lot
more risk because you're gonna pay cash
for whatever you do and you're not gonna
be in a hurry and you know we're gonna
whatever we whatever we spend this 200
grand on it's not 200 down payment and
so we're gonna buy something and own it
and you will make more on that because
you know what you're doing in that world
real estate is much more from an
economics class if you took an econ
class there's a thing called a perfect
market or an imperfect market
more perfect the market the more
everyone has access to it and the less
deals there are real estate is a very
imperfect market meaning that that
meaning that there are deals and you
guys like you and me that know the real
estate world man I bought so much stuff
my net worth tripled in 2008 because I
was buying real estate
I mean I'm buying four million-dollar
buildings four million bucks yeah but
not everybody knows how to do that but I
grew up in that business and so man I
was it was it was kicking it was a fun
time and you could be so great being yes
that heavy yes I don't wanna say
cash-poor but just you're not terrible
yeah what I'm having a problem getting
over that thought process I'm so used to
seeing such a big amount in my my bank
account and I know for some of the
listeners they might be saying well but
if is not enough raise the hundred I
don't care yeah but but but establish a
number that beyond that you quit wasting
the money and you start investing it yes
give yourself some kind of an emotional
baseline where you say if it's not a
hundred it's a hundred and fifty I don't
care if it's two hundred two hundred
sends rich to me but I think a hundred
is plenty personally just talking to you
but establish that baseline and then
pass that say I'm gonna put the next
batch into real estate and I may do the
next batch into mutual funds yeah next
time you get your hands on one hundred
you may call your advisor and drop that
into Mutual's I don't care I haven't I
like having a mix of the two personally
some people don't like real estate some
people don't like mutual funds that's
okay you do any of those you want to do
I'm fine all the way around but that's
the idea you just got to give yourself
some checks and balances with some
guidelines that you just self
established you and your wife talk about
it you pray through it you go okay this
is how much I need to feel good and it
past that I'm gonna force myself to
invest it because past that I'm just
being chicken and there's a difference
between being risk averse and being
chicken you did so good man well done